very strange story in the news I got to
talk about this out of Canada this was
really odd this news out of Canada and I
Andy what are you doing oh I'm sorry I'm
just having a little snack I didn't have
lunch
it's a carrots and Tutsi key I made it
myself
you should try some Steve's got some for
you there are you talking about okay
that's weird
wow this is good Andy how to make this
well Conan why don't you take a look
it's time for light bytes with me Andy
Richter hey everybody welcome to light
bytes
today we're going to be talking about
one of my favorite light bites satsuki
which is a traditional yogurt dipping
sauce dating back to ancient Greece and
the trade routes of the Ottoman Empire
it's also a word that no one knows how
to spell we're gonna start with 1 cup of
Greek yogurt 1 seeded grated and drained
English cucumber 2 cloves of minced
garlic a tablespoon of lemon zest a
tablespoon need what the hell are you
doing in my yard I can explain what you
see I just I was at my house
and then Andy and it you made a cooking
show in your neighbor's backyard and
then you beat him up
yeah it's called light bites yeah okay
look well that look like kind of a big
outdoor shoot how much did all that cost
oh it was it was like 80 grand it was
expensive 80 grand yeah where'd you get
$80,000
whoa Conan why don't you take a look
it's time for quick cash would be Andy
Richter hey there today we're gonna be
robbing a bank all you really need is
some standard panty hose a bag and of
course one of these I'll be right back
hey everybody listen I'm robbing you no
no it's okay
Annie Annie you robbed a bank how are
you not arrested for that Oh Conan this
is LA take a look it's time for cop
kisses with me Andy Richter sir do you
know anything about the armed robbery at
the wait a second you're Conan's guy
Andy Richter that's right
my dog is a big fan of the show can you
get tickets to a taping well do you
think you can forget about that armed
robbery
what armed robbery oh my god
Wow
and II all I gotta say is you are a
terrible guy well maybe but at least
Rigby likes me right Rigby
what's not an acceptable ending of the
sketch it well it is technically that
policeman's dog it just delights me to
see that dog in the audience nothing
makes me happier than a dog watching I
know I know the audience let's give it
up for
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you